I have placed two points on my Argand
diagram this guy and this guy why have I
done that because they're my points of
reference okay and I've got two of them
because there's this guy and then
there's this guy right now let's just
think about this step by step and let's
see the shape that emerges okay Oh
inducing a little bit unusual like over
here we'll do a big trial air and see
how that helps us okay trial and error
is often kind of proof you dislike far
as what you do when you don't know
anything else guess what mathematicians
who are actually doing real matters
frequently don't know anything else so
let's try something I is n plus 1 okay
so this guy over here is the one
measuring from this point of reference
do you agree does that make sense okay
now what I'm going to suggest is let's
just let's just look around okay let's
imagine i'm going to look off in a
certain direction ok let's wonder let's
find out if there is a said that lies
somewhere on this line i'll pick this
this line i've picked it on purpose but
you could draw it any way you like in
fact we're getting for a few more suit
so tell me on this diagram where is argh
z+ 1 where is it how would you describe
yeah very good very good it's in between
the blue line I don't have one more
thing on to that and the positive
direction of the real axis right because
that's the NICU direction and that's not
the liq Christmas right ok so here here
is I goes there but Austin what do you
hear that ok now if that's what I use M
plus 1 it's and follow along with me on
your diagram ok where could i draw
Argives there plus 1 plus pile to Rick
Kuhn I draw would that mean what would
that look like
I'm going to take that angle and then
I'm going to add a right angle to it do
you agree with that so I'm going to say
okay well let me draw this guy
everything that's like a right angle
gauge agree with that so this angle here
is our girls n plus 1 plus pi or two
okay that's the size of it okay but the
size of this apparently should match the
size of this that's what that means
right like this angle that you just help
me draw that should be the angle from
where where am I measuring out from over
here okay the arguments are the same so
this argument that aren't even there
okay that should be the argued measure
from here let me draw that in something
like that it's this obtuse angle right
and it's going to be parallel do move
that like that's what it means for them
to be the same argument the safe side ok
so now I can draw this guy in something
wanted to draw something like that do
you agree they look parallel enough yeah
okay now these wasn't really interesting
right how long the clip in geometry of
what we've done here if these two lines
are parallel right look in particular
and this angle here and the same we can
tell me what kinds of angles they are if
these two lines are parallel I'll put my
finger on it these these are alternate
angles right and also angles on parallel
lines are even right okay now i just
found one of the Zips that guy there
right because when i think about our
exam plus one if you add PI answer to
that you'll get argues n minus 1 right
so that point there is one of my Zeds ok
but remember that first line I drew it
was arbitrary I could run it anywhere
right so i can draw other wines from
negative 1 and i can repeat this process
but i don't want to have to
I just want to notice this guy right
that angle between these two vectors is
always going to be play on to because
I'll always have this alternator does
that make sense so I want to find some
other places where I'm going to get an
angle of PI on to between my vectors
right let me let me draw it on for you
how about this one right I can draw that
one that's going to be an isosceles
triangle I could draw another one over
here that's like like that that's gonna
close up to name in one and yellow hold
on a second or a whole bunch of angles
they're all play on too and they seem to
tracy out this kind of arc right it's
not just any arc it's a semicircle tell
me why it's a semicircle because the
angle of the semicircle is a right angle
it's like a certain company one of the
first ones you learn it's really easy
proved so therefore this traces out ok
I've got a hollow circle here because
you can't measure value hollow so can
keep up into that one and then you've
got this semicircle that makes this one
so you can actually just talking the
equation of this was that it's the unit
circle writes the unit circle it's the
top half of the unit circle ok so I I
can't like I can't be at the oh I can't
be at the end points so i have to
restrict my finally the bottom for that
that's a great question so i can now
think okay well i got this guy over here
what if i drew some Lions down here what
if I do okay now if I go and draw my
line
dunf young and then I repeat my process
you know you add your plan to it shits
up and then you try and find a point
where those things match okay just think
about this for a second I just drawn
alone if I repeat this planet to thing
that's going to be facing like in that
direction is LeBron angle and then the
next step step I did was I drew that
power line from here and he'll go over
here and where do those two intersect
enter they never intercept right because
remember these are not lions they are
graves right so he never comes down this
way he's measuring up and there's the
argument does that make sense so you see
a lot of rays whenever you're measuring
arguments because they've drawn the
point of reference they're not ones that
just go on forever because what else to
do so therefore the semicircle now quick
question for you and I actually read it
in red and i'll let you have a think
about this until tuesday what if i
change this angle what effect you have
if i change it to pile on for you're
clearly not going to get a semicircle
anymore because the aim on a semicircle
is planned to that are you going to
guess what would it what would it look
like well you have a go and i will show
you my answer on tuesday